[Musik]
willkommen in new Tara einer sich selbst
versorgenden Stadt in der
äquatorialregion des Planeten Mars new
Terror wurde von einer multinationalen
Koalition aus Regierungen und privaten
Organisationen errichtet und ist ein
leuchtendes Beispiel dafür was die
Menschheit erreichen kann wenn sie auf
ein gemeinsames Ziel hinarbeitet
im Herzen der Stadt befindet sich ein
Netz unterirdischer Lebensräume und
Gewächshäuser die den Bewohnern ein
komfortables und nachhaltiges Wohnumfeld
bieten und die sie vor kosmischer
Strahlung schützen modernste
Energiesysteme versorgen die Stadt
darunter Solarzellen Windturbinen und
Kernreaktoren
fortschrittliche Transportsysteme und
Technologien erleichtern den Transport
von Menschen und Gütern über die riesige
maßoberfläche aufgrund der geringen
Schwerkraft und der niedrigeren
Produktionskosten haben viele
internationale Unternehmen
Produktionsstätten auf dem Mars
errichtet die von der Herstellung von
Konsumgütern bis zur Entwicklung von
Hightech Geräten reichen
darüber hinaus bietet die einzigartige
Umgebung des Mars ein Zentrum für
Forschung und Entwicklung in Bereichen
wie Technologie Planetenforschung und
Astrobiologie mehrere
Forschungsinstitute und Universitäten
haben Niederlassungen in der Stadt
errichtet und wenn es ums Feiern geht
weiß new Tara wie man es richtig macht
der marsianische Unabhängigkeitstag ist
eine besonders aufregende Zeit nicht nur
aufgrund der Schwerkraft trotzenden
bounce races die sich die geringere
Schwerkraft des Planeten zu Nutze machen
ein einzigartiges marsianisches Erlebnis
dass man nicht verpassen sollte
[Musik]
willkommen in ehres diese einzigartige
Stadt schwebt hoch über der rauen
Oberfläche des Planeten wo Druck und
Temperatur für menschliches Leben
günstiger sind
dank eines luftschiffnetzes dass die
Stadt in der Luft hält kann er es an
verschiedene Orte in der Venusatmosphäre
verlegt und an sich verändernde
Bedürfnisse der Bewohner modular
angepasst werden
er es dient als Forschungs- und
Entwicklungszentrum und bietet
Wissenschaftlern eine einzigartige
Plattform um die Atmosphäre der Venus
untersuchen und mehr über die Geschichte
des Planeten zu erfahren
zu verstehen wie sich das Klima des
Planeten zu seinem heutigen Zustand
entwickelt hat könnte wertvolle
Erkenntnisse über die Faktoren liefern
die den Klimawandel auf der Erde
beeinflussen
die hohe CO2-Konzentration auf der Venus
macht aus eres eine grüne Stadt im Parks
hydroponischen Gärten und Gewächshäusern
wird frisches Obst und Gemüse angebaut
dass ein Grundnahrungsmittel der
einzigartigen Küche von RS ist
apropos Essen Besucher zögern oft die
lokale Delikatesse arianischer
Tintenfisch zu probieren der trotz
seines gruseligen Aussehens überraschend
köstlich ist
am Tag des Himmels verwandelt sich die
Stadt in einen Karneval der Farben und
des Lichts die Menschen steigen in
Heißluftballons und Luftschiffen in die
Lüfte und füllen den Himmel mit einem
Kaleidoskop aus Farben und Klängen
[Musik]
die celestial Quest ist ein
generationenraumschiff dass sich auf die
größte Entdeckungsreise begibt die je
von der Menschheit unternommen wurde ihr
Ziel ist das nächstgelegene
Sternensystem Alpha Centauri das über
vier Lichtjahre von unserem Sonnensystem
entfernt ist doch diese Reise ist nicht
nur eine technische Meisterleistung die
habitatssektion des Schiffes bietet
alles was für ein komfortables Leben
benötigt wird einschließlich Wohnräume
Essbereiche und Freizeiteinrichtungen
Menschen aus allen
Gesellschaftsschichten leben und
arbeiten hier zusammen und bilden eine
eng verbundene Gemeinschaft
ein eindrucksvolles Beispiel für diesen
kulturellen Reichtum ist das von
Generationen von Künstlern geschaffene
Wand gemelde dass ich über das gesamte
Zentrum der celestial Quest erstreckt
Sport und Erholung sind ebenfalls
wichtige Aspekte des Lebens der
Fitnessraum der Swimmingpool die Virtual
Reality Spielsysteme und die Kinosäle
des Schiffes bieten Möglichkeiten für
Bewegung und Entspannung die Besatzung
nimmt auch an Sportarten in
Schwerelosigkeit teil darunter der
beliebte Zero g Fußball
trotz der vielen Herausforderungen mit
denen die Besatzung im Laufe der Jahre
konfrontiert wurde von
asteroidenkollisionen bis hin zu
politischen Unruhen hat sie sich nicht
unterkriegen lassen und ihre Mission
fortgesetzt ihr Engagement für die
Erforschung und Entdeckung ist
ungebrochen und sie setzen sich
weiterhin dafür ein die Grenzen des
menschlichen Wissens und Verständnisses
zu erweitern
wie ihr wisst experimentieren wir hier
auf Dr Watson auch gerne mal rum und da
wir alle Filme Macher sind probieren wir
uns auch gerne an filmischen Ideen aus
das letzte Mal haben wir z.B 6 KI
Szenarien vorgestellt und diese mit
Hilfe von KI bebildert jetzt sind wir
aber noch einen Schritt weitergegangen
für dieses Video haben wir mit Regisseur
und animationsexperte mit Maler
zusammengearbeitet sowohl der Text als
auch alle Bilder und noch ein paar
Extras wurden von KI generiert und ich
muss sagen die Qualität hat mich
wirklich beeindruckt so einen Kurzfilm
von Hand zu erstellen hätte Monate
gedauert das war jetzt ca eine Woche
Arbeit also wie genau haben wir das
gemacht nun insgesamt gab es vier
Schritte als erstes haben wir mit GPT
geschrieben das kennen zwischen
wahrscheinlich alle kein Produkt der
Weltgeschichte hat nämlich jemals so
schnell 100 Millionen aktive Nutzer
gewonnen
wie einem Schauspieler haben wir jeggy
BT als allererstes mal eine Rolle
gegeben du bist ein Experte für
interplanetare menschliche
Zivilisationen der Zukunft und dann
haben wir jebt einen Befehl gegeben
erzähle mir über die Stadt auf dem Mars
wie würde sie aussehen was muss man
unbedingt gesehen haben wie leben die
Menschen und wie sieht ihre Kultur aus
und dann gab es quasi eine Art
Interviewsituation die ersten
Beschreibungen waren häufig sehr
generisch aber mit gezieltem nachfragen
konnte man Chat GPT sehr interessante
Details entlocken Chat GPT merkt sich
alles worüber man in einer Unterhaltung
geredet hat und am Ende haben wir dann
darum gebeten dass die interessantesten
Infos zusammengefasst werden und das war
dann unser finaler Text das alles haben
wir auf Englisch gemacht kann zwar auch
Deutsch aber auf englisch kriegt man
einfach beeindruckendere Ergebnisse
finde ich vermutlich weil es hier mehr
Trainingsdaten gibt den finalen Text
haben wir dann mit depel übersetzt was
aber ja auch wieder eine kai ist also
schon die zweite Kai als nächstes haben
dann Chat GPT gebeten uns präzise
Beschreibungen für die verschiedenen
Locations zu liefern diese haben wir
dann in mit journey gefüttert das ist
ein KI bildgenerierungsprogramm sowie
auch stable Diffusion oder Dali als Deal
haben wir Stichworte wie Science Fiction
cinematic oder futuristic benutzt und
die Ergebnisse waren wirklich mega
beeindruckend ich kann gar nicht genug
betonen wie krass es ist dass man
inzwischen mit ein paar Worten täuschend
echt aussehende Fotos kreieren kann die
man quasi nicht oder kaum noch von
echten unterscheiden kann es ist
wirklich mein blowing und was das alles
noch an Implikationen für uns haben wird
das können wir uns wahrscheinlich gerade
noch gar nicht vorstellen einen ersten
Vorgeschmack haben wir aber ja mit dem
Bild vom Papst bekommen dass viele
fälschlicherweise für echt hielten es
hat richtig viel Spaß gemacht die Bilder
zu erstellen und alles fühlte sich eher
wie eine Entdeckungstour an so als ob
man neue Welten entdeckt und sie
gleichzeitig auch noch aktiv
mitgestaltet indem man die besten Bilder
auswählt und diese dann weiterent
insgesamt haben wir circa 1000 Bilder
erstellen lassen und es war wirklich
super schwierig sich von einigen dieser
Bilder zu trennen deswegen zeigen wir
euch hier auch noch mal ein paar
richtige Perlen die es leider nicht ins
Video geschafft haben
ursprünglich wollten wir euch auch Dinge
zeigen die nicht so gut geklappt haben
zum Beispiel Planeten in der venusstadt
oder so richtig creepyige Gesichter aber
während wir an dem Video gearbeitet
haben ist die neue Version von mit
journey rausgekommen und die hat dann
einen Großteil der Probleme beseitigt
was ziemlich gut Zeit wie schnell sich
hier gerade alles weiterentwickelt jeden
Tag kommen neue Updates neue Tools coole
Tricks und Tipps werden entwickelt und
neue Workflows kommen raus die
Veränderungsrate im Bereich KI ist
gerade unglaublich groß
aber das sind ja nur statische Bilder
natürlich wollen wir die auch animieren
können ist ja immerhin ein
Animationsfilm und keine Diashow auch
dafür haben wir natürlich eine KI
benutzt die kann die Tiefe eines Bildes
erkennen und das als Schwarz-Weiß-Bild
darstellen das nennt man defmap und die
wird dann dazu verwendet einen 3D-Modell
zu generieren leider kann man dann aber
noch hier und da Verzerrungen erkennen
sobald man die Kamera bewegt noch eine
weitere KI erkennt daher die Kanten des
Bildes und erstellt neue Teile des
Bildes die von Objekten im Vordergrund
verdeckt wären die KI errät also quasi
was sich hinter Objekten befinden würde
kleiner fun fact am Rande wir haben für
den Film 70 Shots erstellen lassen für
jeden einzelnen shot muss man die
gleichen Arbeitsschritte machen
Importieren des 3D-Modells in das
Animationsprogramm Blender Zuweisen von
Texturen rotierung des Modells Erstellen
einer Kamera etc
wir haben uns gedacht diese ganze Arbeit
muss doch nicht sein hey
kannst du uns nicht ein Pfeifen Script
schreiben dass all diese Schritte
automatisiert und tatsächlich hat das
schon beim allerersten Versuch perfekt
geklappt und wir konnten so ca 10
Minuten Arbeit pro shot sparen also
insgesamt knapp 12 Stunden Arbeit die
wir eingespart haben natürlich geht noch
nicht alles mit nur einem einzigen
Knopfdruck vieles im Film ist immer noch
manuelle Handarbeit gewesen der Schnitt
die Musik Kamera Animationen und die
Effekte wurden alle ohne KI hinzugefügt
und auch meine Stimme haben wir noch
ganz klassisch im Studio aufgenommen es
gibt zwar schon richtig coole Tools und
stimmen zu generieren oder zu klonen
aber die funktionieren alle noch nicht
so gut auf Deutsch in Englisch
trotzdem künstliche Intelligenz hat uns
ermöglicht all diese Prozesse viel viel
schneller zu machen einen solchen
fünfeinhalb minütigen Kurzfilm in nur
etwa einer Woche zu erstellen wäre für
eine Person vor einem Jahr noch
undenkbar gewesen was gerade im Bereich
KI passiert ist monumental es ist die
Zukunft nur dass Sie heute schon da ist
viele Bereiche unserer Gesellschaft
werden sich verändern und das schneller
als es die allermeisten erwarten ich
glaube dass viele noch nicht erkannt
haben dass wir gerade einen kritischen
Punkt überschritten haben KI war lange
Zeit ein spannendes Zukunftsthema wir
haben hier auf Dr Watson viel darüber
gesprochen wie sie mathematisch
funktioniert was die Fallstricke sein
könnten und wie die Zukunft mit KI
aussehen könnte die vor und die
Nachteile aber jetzt ist sie da und das
ist ein bisschen scary aber ich glaube
auch dass es wichtig ist sich nicht
davor zu verschließen so wie jede
Technologie kann man sie zum Guten und
zum Schlechten einsetzen und gerade bei
einer Technologie die so disruptiv ist
wie KI muss man wissen wie sie
funktioniert ich hoffe wir konnten euch
hier einen Überblick liefern und zeigen
wie man diese Technologie einsetzen kann
und seine Kreativität zu befeuern und
Neues zu erschaffen wenn ihr selber mal
diese ganzen kitools ausprobieren wollt
und eure eigene Welt kreieren wollt dann
schaut mal bei Mix Channel vorbei hier
findet ihr ein Tutorial wie das alles
selber nachmachen könnt und jetzt kommt
eine von Chat GPT geschriebene Werbung
die wir wirklich beim allerersten
Versuch genauso bekommen haben wie ich
sie jetzt vorlese
hey leute wisst ihr was die
gefährlichste Kreatur im Internet ist
nein nicht der Tastatur Krieger oder der
Social Media Stalker es ist der Daten
Halt und heute präsentiere ich euch den
ultimativen Schutz gegen diese fiesen
ungeheuer nordvpn nordvpn ist wie ein
magisches Cape dass euch unsichtbar
macht und überall hin teleportiert ihr
wollt Netflix in der Antarktis gucken
kein Problem nordvpn bringt euch dahin
ohne dass ihr eure Couch verlassen müsst
aber warte es wird noch besser nordvpn
ist schneller als Usain Bolt auf Koffein
also keine Angst vor nervigen Ladebalken
oder ruckeln in den Videos mehr und für
alle paranoika da draußen paranoika
keine Sorge nordvpn ist so dicht wie ein
U-Boot eure Daten sind als die Rezepte
von Oma apropos wusstet ihr schon dass
Chat GPT in Italien gesperrt wurde aber
keine Sorge mit nordvpn könnt ihr auch
dort problemlos darauf zugreifen einfach
per VPN verbinden und los geht's also
worauf wartet ihr noch klickt auf den
Link unten um ein Zweijahresabo von
nordvpn abzuschließen und erhaltet
unglaubliche vier Monate gratis zeig den
datenhain wer der Boss ist und surft
sorgenfrei das war die Werbung die ich
wirklich gerade genauso vorgelesen habe
wie wir sie bekommen haben und ich bin
sehr beeindruckt auf der einen Seite und
beunruhigt auf der anderen Seite
schreibt mir gerne mal unten in die
Kommentare was ihr von der aktuellen
Veränderungsrate von KI haltet und ob
ihr das genauso sieht wie ich ich bin
gespannt was sie zu sagen habt wie immer
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig
[Musik]
und es gibt ja schon ein erstes
ki-magazin das wirklich komplett von der
Karriere erstellt wurde das habe ich
noch gar nicht gemacht